[Music]
there's a really Hey Joe can you give me
a water yeah thank you leave all by the
way so we got a uh we got a a viewer
named Judith and she's asking the
million-dollar
question why are you
gay that is that would be the million
dollar
question why are you gay I watch it
really opens up the mind are gay why are
you Gad do you believe that um once a
cheater always a cheater oo I do but
it's such a generic thing though because
like when like were they you were in
marriage yet or like were you in high
school or cuz for me if you're like a
mature person and you're in a marriage
and you cheat then yeah once cheater
always cheat but if it's like you
cheated at a when you were 15 with your
like high school it's not the same is it
cheting if you're just jacking off and
watching porn
definitely if the rules of your
relationship are that you you can't do
that then wouldn't it be I don't cuz
isn't cheating just breaching the rules
of your own relationship I agree
whatever the parameters are par are I
think for me it's um so I learned I
guess about a healthy relationship
backwards oh so my parents are divorced
right so I think I don't think they were
like a good role model to me um cuz I
got divorced when I was six so you know
how they say like you model your
relationship based off of like I don't
know whatever is the healthiest one
around you yeah the one that I saw that
was the healthiest were my grandparents
and ever since I was a kid my
grandparents they would like after
dinner they'd go to the park down the
street they go for a walk and they're
like arm in- arm they're like looking at
flowers and stuff and just as a kid I'm
like wow it's so beautiful to see like
how they're so like in each other's
lives they're extremely involved like um
uh like my grandma like to smoke
cigarettes before she takes a nap so my
Grandpa would be like like his rounds
around the house would be like oh has
two cigarettes left and then so when he
goes to the supermarket he'll like get
that stuff ready like he he's very
attentive to like her needs you know and
or like oh oh her blood pressure
medicine is low so I like I'll take a
note of that and then I'll see her do
the same thing for him where it's like
she's like okay like he likes to eat
this or we go down to the supermarket oh
cool this meat is on sale this is what
your Grandpa loves to eat so they're
very very like in tune and they they
always just try to make each other's
life
better and I so that was my idea of like
a good
relationship and then it wasn't until
later when my Grandma had Alzheimer's
and she would start screaming crazy [__]
it'll be like in the middle of dinner
but you cheated on me oh [__] yeah
that's when it came out what the [__]
and I would ask my mom like did that
happen he goes like yeah so Grandpa used
to work on a ship and then you know he
had a affair cuz it' be like out into
whatever so it was confirmed Grandpa
needed [__] he's been out in the sea
for 6 months but I think as a kid it
gets molded where like something
beautiful can still be created out of
like like a crazy [__] up you know yeah
if people two people are still willing
to work at it and I was like did it ever
happen again like no he felt so bad that
you know like all these things do you
think does that mean that when they when
you weren't around let's say that it was
just them two that they probably were
fighting about it still no this is like
uh when my mom was a kid oh so it's like
a buried thing that they don't even
bring I mean clearly she still thought
about it which is kind of what I'm
saying is like once a cheater always a
cheater because you always in in that
Rel in in the context of that
relationship right you there's always
that layer that was mistrust and you bro
you violated that trust and so it seems
like she even remembered it like
obviously when she had Dimension ship
yeah and I just think that that's a
hugely damaging thing to happen to a
relationship like I'm not saying you
can't continue and all that kind of
stuff but they always have that memory
it doesn't go away you can't lobotomize
the memory so it [__] with the trust
that's all that's my thoughts yeah I
think any violation within friendships
relationships or anything it does make
it you you create another element by
tainting it yeah but then coming back
from it there are cases of mhm great
times you know it's like yeah that [__]
sucks but you know we're we're we're we
learned and if two mature adults and
just go like let's move on from this I'm
not going to hate on that go for it
that's how it should be it should be
forgiveness and and it's like well let's
you know keep going forward but I think
the the point I'm hearing from you is
that no matter what it does taint it and
it becomes like a kind of a stain on on
something pure that you had yeah and and
you can build on bad land you just have
to put more concrete down and all this
other stuff but like you you always you
always remember though what you had to
do to get your house that way and I just
don't think that goes away oh it doesn't
go away but I feel like for those that
can overcome it it'll probably be like
look at how strong our love is because
we were able to be tested sure and
overcame it yep yeah but I don't know
it's it's tough like because when you're
younger it's more like you think in
absolutes like I would never [__]
cheat I would never do this you know
yeah yeah yeah and then you're actually
presented with the with the with the
position like young guys right like if
you're virgin and also like you've never
been in the situation where you're like
damn there's a hot ass 10 right in front
of me and she's just down to give me a
if you've never even yeah you know how
they say like the more successful the
more um powerful all these things high
value men it technically it actually
becomes harder cuz you have more
temptation but if you're like an incel
[__] basement dweller you're like
like abstinence and it's
like know like yeah cuz no one wants to
[__] no one wants to [__] that's why
you're like I'm a champion for
abstinence and it's like yeah but it's
you're you're not by choice versus The
Rock or Jason Mamoa goes you know what
guys I'm abstinent and everyone's like
what the [__] seriously so I think
that's I think that's the difference is
like can you be asent after me oh God or
like those those guys out there that are
like you know like violence is not the
answer it's like but you look like a
[__] you can't even fight what the [__]
of course not so you're it's like you
got to be capable of it the answer then
yeah it's like I think violence is the
answer always and I still can't fight
it's like a capable guy it's a capable
guy that chooses not to do it it's like
a guy that's like you know what man I'm
not [__] any girls and it's like but
none of the girls want you so of course
you're never going to cheat cuz you
never are presented with the opportunity
yeah but in in uh you know how you were
saying what was interesting is that like
let's say you cheated when you were 15
and then you're like married to someone
totally different at like 35 it's
probably not going to bleed over to like
your reputation is not going to be like
oh I don't know if I can trust you as a
wife you know but if you were giving
advice to a 15-year-old let's say like a
a 15-year-old girl who's dating and
she's dating a 15-year-old guy who just
cheated get the [__] away from that
idiot yeah so you'd be like oh he might
be in a phase right unless you're the
girl he cheated for
like you the mistress yeah but like is
once a cheater always a cheater within
the window of like 14 to 18 you know
like in that you're so young you don't
know who the hell you are any anyway
like until you're until you're like you
know you're established somewhat and
you've you've you know like Nicks had
one relationship he sucks he says all
the time if TI cheated it's murder
suicide murder suicide homicide yep so
but if you've been mulally cheated on
and he's not like a virgin s [__] or
whatever I I kind of am but he's just a
s [__] yeah cuz they' had not virgin
anymore but I was a one oh [__] I didn't
know that I was a virgin for a little
bit that's sick dude I was born virgin
too you me really that's pretty cool but
yeah you know the cuz I distinctly
remember being in high school and like
if anybody had ever cheated on anybody
it was like totally damaging My First
Girlfriend nobody would date that person
I think that's what Joe is saying where
like when you're when you're young
you're extremely idealistic everything's
a big deal like and then when you get
older you kind of see more of the world
like I remember um what is it called I
had a friend his dad owned a
business and he was telling me this
story where his dad's right-hand man
they found out that he was been
embezzling from that company for 10
years wow and it was his best friend too
holy [__] I was like what the [__]
that's [__] crazy I was like what did
your dad do and then he was like he
obviously he was pissed and his first
instinct was to fire him but I think the
the I don't know empathy or whatever
side took over and I was like dude what
compelled you to do that so he actually
gave him a second chance and then he
helped the company perform better than
it ever has for the next 10 years he's
like thank you for forgiving me and then
he's like I'm never going to steal and
then and he made the company better yeah
and so when you're younger you're like
man if any of the homies stole from me
or whatever it's just I'm King that
[__] black and white you know
but then as you get older and you see
different parts of like how people
operate you're like w that's interesting
that's crazy I never thought of like but
finding out what people's motivations
were that's really important too I guess
I also just think there's no like
blanket statements though you know what
I mean cuz it's also like absolutes yeah
absolutes just you could you could be
like forgiving and then it could be like
you know 10x like in return or he jacks
you again yeah you know what's
interesting though is I imagine that
like as we go through life you get older
you get rid of the absolutes but for
some reason I imagine that when once I
have a daughter my absolutes are going
to come
back in the form of like do you think
you're going to love your daughter more
than your son like no you're not going
to date that [__] guy he cheated on
you yeah like all your absolutes come
back when you're thinking of but that's
those are formative years where like you
should respect yourself you should you
should know to create a boundary and say
no [__] way I'm not going to take
this actually if it was your daughter if
my daughter was 45 years old okay and
she's always single getting into
divorces like five times MH I'm going to
be like maybe you should reconsider
St that's really good you've been
cheating they've been cheating you guys
how many times have you cheated she goes
like 15 yeah
exactly scarios come on you know hey
dude like no one's a saint here I think
it depends that's true though H what if
she's what you've done what your
partner's done the history I think like
depending on that person it's like if
you live throughout life virgin never
did anything
virgin
then I would tell my daughter dude how
the [__] that's horrible don't give this
[__] a second chance yeah cuz you know
what you know what happened my first
girlfriend she left she lost her
virginity to another guy cheating on me
well I was a
virgin God I'm not going to it's a
dagger it was it was crazy it was crazy
but I was like after that like I was
like how can I that's I'm not going to
lose my virginity to her now yeah yeah
dudee she's two she'll be 2 and 0 she's
tained taking everyone's vcards dude
yeah bro but then you know that you know
that like that sentence that just makes
I don't know that's a imaginary dad it
makes my hard drop the sentence of dad
he cheated on me oh what's the advice
like how what's the consolation you're
thinking about a you'll survive you're
thinking about a cute [__]
18-year-old I'm thinking about a
45-year-old [__] that's like why dude
keep [__] up what's your advice to
your 17-year-old daughter grandparents
cheated that's what I
say who's Bart and all is okay it does
depend on the kid cuz then like Tao was
like me and Robin aren't friends anymore
I'm like what did you do okay yeah yeah
you know I think it depends on the kid I
think I would ask her um I I know it
sucks but do you imagine yourself
marrying this guy oh cuz they don't
think that far and she's like not
anymore yeah yeah yeah that's her then
go then why you wasting time why you
[__] wasting time with this guy the
problem is they do think that far at
that age bro I remember being that age
and they think they're going to marry
him first person you're with you're like
oh we're going to get married and all
this and i' say that's why it hurts so
bad already doubl down already your
[__] composition notebook you're like
writing their name 600 times then you go
you don't have this perspective the
magical perspective of Jo talking about
here I go are you going to marry this
person and like no of course not well
then it's time to move on of course they
don't think that this was going to be my
[__] husband dude Squire she goes
you're going to have six kids so she
goes daddy love of my life oh no you
don't know how much I want to marry this
guy I was like all right yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah put him on the phone uhhuh
tell him come over what's up Mr jitsuwa
all right you 40-year-old [__] I know
my sweet ass 18-year-old girl can he I
like where I'm 38 why is everyone 40
she's the same age you need to stay away
from 40y old they're the same class I
we're going to take a walk all right my
daughter wants to marry you yeah yeah
going to be very happy I was like honey
go to your room I'll be like you
[__] [__] all right you see
what this knife he's like hurry up I got
to go to work in 5 minutes fing knife
you [__] [__]
exactly I'll [__] cut your dick off
with this dull plastic knife oh o that's
actually you're going to propose to her
and make her [__] happy and if you
ever cheat on her or anything again I'm
going to cut your dad's dick off and
stuff it down your throat dad dick is
good my dad's
dead I'll I'll dig your dad up I'll cut
his dick off and I'll shove it down your
throat how about that how's that for a
boner boom wow say welcome to the family
shake his hand I'm dating another
18-year-old I'm done you're going to
force them to be together I'm yeah so I
you know what it is I am a very like big
proponent of you made your [__] bed
sleep in it right so if she goes want to
marry this guy and I'm all like all
right if you think that's a great idea
and hopefully by this time she knows how
my mind operates and I let her dig her
own grave until she learns her own
lesson wow then I go you think that's a
great idea all right then you should
marry him so this is the like I got
caught smoking cigarettes and now I got
to smoke cigarettes y now she has to
[__] be with this guy and if he
becomes a nuisance to the family and
he's like causing all these issues then
he's got more family advents he's got to
be eliminated
you catch your sweet 17-year-old
daughter in like a giant orgy oh then I
say honey get out of here and I took off
my clothes and start [__] all of them
they're 17 oh never mind oh God I didn't
think they were young then you send her
then you send her to to a bigger or I
thought they were all my age oh my
goodness he's all send them where send
her to a bigger orgy cuz then she'll
really learn
yeah I mean with her having my genetics
she probably would be Kazumi
2.0 okay not that I'm going to raise her
this way well I mean Hannah will
probably have some say just a little bit
but mhm okay I don't know man it's
difficult because I think everyone's
initial reaction is like get the [__]
out of there what are you doing this
guy's an idiot
yeah but it does tell me that they have
a weak character if they if they go back
to a cheater no the cheater oh yeah they
lack discipline yeah yeah I like I mean
that's like being a druggie or whatever
like you're addicted to something and
then you just you just fail for a little
bit couldn't control yourself yeah lack
of self-control as a Dad what's your
feelings let's say daughter I would say
differently if they were married oh yeah
yeah of course it's a different it's a
different thing daughter 17 she got a
boyfriend he cheated on her she's crying
to you Dad should I stay with him I love
him he probably wouldn't do it again
right translator that exists that can
translate dog language that's why you
can hear oh my God so
much wait your pug 17 the Pug's about to
pass away in dog years or human years
dog years guacamole everywh yeah they
dating is past them you know um if I had
a daughter I would say you have an
absolute in this situation or are you
very open to like I think chances are I
think look yeah of course you know they
could work it out and be fine together
but at that age I'd probably be like cut
your losses and move on let me ask you
something what if you like really
[__] like this kid
more than your daughter ooh that'd be
hard that' be hard star player at the
same know that can happen but at the
same time though like if you like you
said he's a star player I'd be like oh
dude you're [__] this is going to be
your life this is what you're going to
be doing like like what if he was like
your Jiu-Jitsu prot you love this dude
[__] amazing it would hurt even more
but not only does he cheat on your
daughter but beats her up oh my God what
the
cuz sometimes and you taught him how to
beat her up you like it more you like it
more then I'm a piece of then I adopt
him no then then it's I think it's more
on me right cuz I think it's like oh I
[__] up if you adopt him then it's
your son and
daughter having sex yeah never mind I'm
not going to adopt anybody that was a
throwaway okay be a throw away um that
would really make me very sad that would
be I I feel like I I'm a bad parent or
something so who do you beat your
daughter or him that's true who do I
beat up yeah do you beat up your
daughter or you beat up him no I don't
think I beat up my beat up no but I in
the story he likes the son more than the
daughter the guy beat her up just look
Anthony people are getting a lot out of
this prompt right now and we just need
you to calm
down I would have to [__] try to
fight this dude yeah I would have to try
to fight him I like that I like that
he's the one giving you these elements
but you're answering me oh I would have
to try to find
this this by the way started with are is
is once a cheater always a cheater and
then it turned into is it okay if your
daughter's boyfriend cheats and then
beats your daughter kicks your kid's ass
but you really like this guy and you
taught him his moves you're Jiu-Jitsu
Pro your daughter's 45 and she can't get
married no one wants them really well
it's so boring to go with the same
question we already answered yes no now
move
on evolve it yes Steve this is giv
everybody a lot right now I need you to
calm down dude you don't like content
what's
wrong yo all the homies I know that like
would cheat on their girls all the time
like uh damn you got a lot of friends
that are cheater the color of their
belts well
well well a lot of them like they are I
don't want to say they're slaves to
women in a lot of ways but like that's
like their main [__] like your Vice
like they just can't do anything but
like oh I just got to [__] talk to
these [__] all the time so it's like
I don't say once always once a cheater
is always a cheater but like the chances
are that is the case it's like women
addiction yeah like if if they don't
have something that stops them from
doing it like sometimes it is the the
repercussions of okay this guy cheated
on his girl his girl wants to leave he
loves that girl that is the only thing
that'll stop him from wanting to cheat
but if that but I've had friends too
where they had the girl of their life
the love of their life they started
cheating she he wanted to dip but they
stayed together but he still continue to
cheat so it's like yeah that's that's
something he needs to heal first exactly
number one for me dude and by you
already stepping out of your
relationship like that cuz I feel like
once you it's once you open the
floodgates bro it's really hard to stop
yeah yeah like that's the thing so it's
like once you open Pandora's Box I think
it's a lot of times it's it's over for a
lot of people I mean the word in itself
is called cheating I thought you say
Pandora yeah is a great music app that I
use it's called cheating it's not called
[__] fairness and and playing
honorable true called cheating you're
[__] you're cheat yeah ta
Chi so why why do they have the question
is cheating ever okay what kind of
[__] prompt is that that's I mean
that's the question it's it's
contact y the the fact that he's like
what if he's are jiujitsu pro to
J tell me about it dud he beats your
daughter so Ryan is cheating okay what
kind of stupid ass question is that but
you really like him what if he fixes
cars and yours you got a real bad
one it first and then I beat his
ass hope that um Judith I hope you found
some form of answer and all these
variations just make sure you know one
tool and this [__] boxer drawer that
you can probably pull out of maybe yeah
it's a junk drawer though yeah the junk
dra every Tools in here yep we'll
revisit the prompt in a couple weeks
work though let me mature a little bit
more and I'll give you a different
answer